look at the source of white light above
us you see these beautiful rainbow Halos
right but now look behind you at The Joe
Rogan Experience neon light you'll
basically just see the yellow you'll see
the orange because that's made of gases
that only emit light at very very narrow
wavelengths here's another example Joe
this is a laser spot oh yeah I see a
bunch of them you just see a bunch of
green dots but now if I do this here's a
white light
all right Isn't that cool that's
beautiful that's cool right that's
really pretty so this diffraction
grating separates light out into all of
its different wavelengths it's called
the spectrometer now Isaac Newton and
William Herschel figured out something
really cool they said if I believe if I
look at a light source like the sun and
I put a thermometer like right here
where the red comes out over here it
starts to heat up the thermometer gets
warmer and they realize there's light
that you cannot see beyond the red
that's responsible for the perception of
heat that's called infrared radiation